ron and hermione are practicing lifting
feathers into the air with magic
hermione can lift a feather 35 feet in
the air which is five times as high as
ron can lift a feather how high can ron
lift a feather with his magic
so hermione this 35 feet is five times
more than ron so to figure out what ron
can do we just take what hermione can do
and divide by five so what's 35 divided
by five
well five times seven is 35 so 35
divided by 5 is 7. so ron can lift a
feather
77 feet in the air so let's check our
answer and if you have trouble with this
and we could also look at the hints for
this so they show that hermione can lift
a feather 35 feet which is five times
higher than ron so this could be the
length of how high ron can raise it and
so if you were to actually divide 35
into five equal sections so five times
question mark is 35 that's the same
thing as saying 35 divided by 5 is
question mark and 35 divided by 5 is
indeed is indeed 7.